le 6 décembre sans rendez vous à mourir
vite grève auprès de l'utilité les fonds
manquent aujourd'hui tout ce qu'il faut
avoir une négociation avec sur la
représentativité puisque c'est eux qui
doute nous proposons des activités
d'autres activités cette date à
l'utilité nous avons eu deux rencontres
et aucune des rencontres a permis
d'aboutir à un protocole a lieu à as est
négociée à cette demande encore
aujourd'hui le mouvement consiste en
coin qui est mobilisée alors laissé les
membres du bureau de la section
syndication sont mobilisés les agents
sont mobilisés et puis nous on a fait le
forcing en se disant qu'un jour n'ayant
pas de réponse de président de la cacem
mais nous faisons le choix de bloquer le
siège administratif au niveau de la
1 participation consentent à dessein on
veut pas dire puisque aujourd'hui le
directeur général des services a fait
plaquer les agents je pense que c'est
par souci d'image de ne pas voir que de
me rappeler la collectivité de la cacem
la deuxième collectivité de martinique
qui a ouvre de grève qui a ouvre demain
aujourd'hui on va pas dire que c'est 50
que ses 560 simplement on dit simplement
que la casse elle est ancrée rouge